at Paris's Cirque de verre the cast
expects to perform in front of four
houses at this time of the year but amid
the rose and excited children there are
empty seats a drop of 20% in ticket
sales means the public transport strike
is no laughing matter for the bullion a
family that's owned this circus for
almost 90 years it's one of the toughest
seasons they've had we we're doing the
show until 16 of March so if we lose 20
percent every show there's a lot of
money it's a lot of lost but we can't
stop we have contract with there are
teas we are our public already bought
ticket until the 16 of March so we can't
say we stop it's impossible sometimes
it's the performers who are on strike
ballet dancers are against government
plans to reform pensions because for now
they get to retire at 42 after a short
career that puts enormous strains on
their bodies we're against the pension
reform the government wants to implement
but it's also a gesture towards
spectators because we as artists are
very sorry for what's happening to
deprive hundreds of spectators from
Christmas shows the Opera House says
it's lost nine million dollars since the
start of the strike on December the
fifth ticket sales in many Paris
theaters have dropped by as much as a 40
percent and December is their most
important time of the year it's money
they'll not be able to make back just
250 tickets have been sold for tonight's
performance at the 650 seat Teatro de
Montparnasse you know when people have
spent an hour and a half on foot to get
to work it's too much to expect them to
go out again here when the crowd
applauded actors the actors have clouded
the crowd back because they are the real
heroes who've managed to make it here it
is says Bertrand the biggest slump in
theatre going he's experienced in recent
memory
for the performers the show must go on
of course but it's getting harder to
live up to that principle Burnett Smith
al-jazeera
Paris
[Applause]